i'm your host pete heck seth look
outside your window right now
do you see your neighbors fighting in
the streets with bayonets and cannons
when's the last time you saw union and
confederate soldiers charging at each
other
on horseback in case you haven't heard
in case you missed it
we're in the middle of yet another civil
war and the only way to save our
republic
is to make sure democrats completely
control elections
by keeping them nice and wide open
your soul on free and fair elections is
just such a threat
literally i've said it before
we're facing the most significant test
of our democracy
since the civil war that's not hyperbole
since the civil war
literally as the clip goes on he says it
many times how many times
can one human being say literally
without saying anything
that is actually literal but if you
don't believe we're in a civil war maybe
you'll believe
that all republican voting bills are
racist
the 21st century jim crow assault is
real
it's unrelenting it was a doozy it is
unrelenting racism using sheer fear
tactics and of course maximum hyperbole
in their ultimate quest for power well
that's nothing new for the left
but with issues like i don't know rising
crime door-to-door vaccines by the way
we have an update on that
thank you local news the border crisis
and rapid
inflation the task of convincing voters
that jim crow is back at the ballot box
i don't think it's working the american
people and their
sane state legislators they're starting
to catch on
so this week texas democrats well they
tried something new
they chartered a couple of private jets
loaded up a case of beer and fled to
washington dc now why did they do that
because in texas a minimum amount of
lawmakers are required to be
present in order to advance laws by
abandoning the state like
huddled and heroic refugees texas
democrats can avoid their legal
obligation to show up and actually do
their job look at those selfies big old
smiles so proud of themselves
and they get to temporarily prevent the
republican majority from protecting the
ballot box they took like 10 or 15 of
these selfies i mean you can't
it's not hard to find an original today
the jet setting and
suddenly popular texas democrats took
meetings with
chuck schumer and kamala harris both of
whom managed to put their dereliction of
duty
into the proper historical context
in 1867 frederick douglass appealed
to the congress the united states
congress
for the right for black men to vote
1913 women marched
down pennsylvania avenue
for the right to vote in 2021
the texas legislature came to washington
d.c mr smith comes to washington
who knew the 2021 texas legislature on
par
with frederick douglass and the suffrage
movement
put in the textbooks right now
the apocalyptic and historic republican
voting bill included some very
radical restrictions like i don't know
requiring driver's license or social
security numbers
for mail-in voting we're not talking
about uh photocopying ids here we're
just talking about
voter identification for mail-in ballots
beefing up criminal penalties for
election workers who break rules
now we know dems they don't like
penalties especially when you burn
things
and adding an extra hour for early
voting each day from
eight hours which currently is to nine
hours at a minimum
keep in mind texas already has
17 17 days of early
voting on election day good luck texas
voters
how are you going to find 15 minutes
within 17 days
in at least a nine hour window each day
sheer suppression now texas democrats
will eventually have to come back and
do their job governor abbott can
continue to call special sessions
to force this vote unless of course they
plan to flee forever
so why do they go through all that
effort
to stall the inevitable because it's not
just about the lone star state
the texas democrats fled the front lines
they retreated from the voting rights
equivalent of the civil war
not to surrender but to draft federal
reinforcements
we are living right now on borrowed time
in texas and we can't stay here
indefinitely to run out the clock
to stop republican anti-voter
bills that's why we need congress to act
now and pass the for the people act
we need the president and the vice
president and every democrat in this
senate
working together to preserve american
democracy
ah this is a stunt this is about
hr1 this is about federal control of
elections this is about nancy pelosi the
plan is in motion the country is
watching
and the texas democrats they're loving
their newfound media attention
they even decided to inspire fellow
democrats
and all patriots nationwide by
performing this beautiful song
[Music]
there you have it here now a member of
that chorus democrat texas state
representative james talarico who
recently flew on a private plane and
currently resides in washington d.c
james thank you very much for being here
now we know you met with chuck schumer
and nancy pelosi today and
the talking points they've been issued
uh you've been told to say you're
protecting democracy that republicans
are authoritarians and racists they're
blocking the ballot box you want voter
suppression
i've got it texas republicans are racist
but you're in d.c now and the talk is
all about hr1
and from you they're gleefully promoting
your effort
to promote their national effort it kind
of seems like
they're just using you as a prop or a
puppet
so you know i'm an eighth generation
texan i've only been in dc
twice in my life this is the second time
uh i'm a former middle school teacher
who ran for office just to try to make
my community better
and i swore an oath when i first got
elected two years ago
to uphold the constitution the
constitution of the united states
and also the constitution of the great
state of texas and after
our former president donald trump
started his big lie that the election
was stolen
republican legislators and capital how
did you make
so now you're going to voter suppression
which i get it but if this is all about
your allegiance to texas and
you're an 8th generation texan and all
that and the constitution
by the way the constitution section 1
article 4 gives authority to the state
legislatures
then why are you not in texas and why
are you in washington dc doing press
conferences with federal officials
i was just going to answer that um it's
a great question
and what i was saying is when president
trump
lost the election he told republicans
across the country that he didn't lose
the election and this caused republican
legislators
in state capitals from georgia to austin
to start putting forward bills that
would make it harder to vote and
actually it's
texas is one of the hardest places to
vote in the whole country and so when
this started
many of my democratic colleagues tried
to negotiate with our fellow
legislators most of them republicans to
try to make the bill
less damaging less harmful less
dangerous to constituencies across the
state of texas
unfortunately our republican colleagues
didn't want 17
days of early voting and adding an hour
of voting
too much is it too difficult to provide
i don't know your driver's license
number uh and the fast last four digits
of your social security number is that
too much to ask a voter in texas
so what this bill does i'm glad you
asked because it gives you an
opportunity to correct
something you said earlier which is that
this bill actually reduces the amount of
time for early voting oh it does
yeah so in in texas currently a county
can extend voting to 24 hours you can
actually vote
all night which is really convenient if
you work through the day a lot of
working folks aren't able to get off
work to go vote it's voting
in the morning is there it's voting at
2am the morning that is the key issue
is is it is there anyone in texas that's
not currently
able to vote because i've heard the
hyperbole this is jim crow
this is voter repression this is the
civil war from the leadership of your
party
is there currently a single example you
can provide me of a
registered citizen voter in texas that
can't vote
if we're fighting the civil war here
thankfully this bill has not passed yet
and god willing it won't pass no if the
bill passes will there be any
there will be a minority or a woman
that's not able to vote
so the person who oversees elections is
appointed by a republican in the state
of texas it's a republican appointed
secretary of state and she actually said
that texas elections
in the past two cycles were safe smooth
and secure those were the three words
you used
as you pointed out your party has
pointed out time and time again we
needed to expand these things because of
covid and by the way i didn't see a
whole lot of covid going on in that
private plane
uh without those masks but but i digress
so if kovid's not
there and or ultimately minimized in our
application
shouldn't we be making sure that the
rules go go to go back to something that
makes sense that's reasonable that's a
great question i think you know in the
pandemic we learned that a lot of things
can be made more convenient and more
accessible you know a lot of folks are
working from home instead of having to
go into the office uh and that's exactly
what we learned in voting we could we
can change some of our
voting systems are you okay with voter
id are you okay with voter id because
you're going back to the talking points
i get it the talking points have been
issued
are are you okay with voter id so voter
id is currently required in the state of
texas i i opposed having to
how about having to send your foreign in
should you have to prove who you are
because that's what democrats are
opposing pete i just said i i oppose
voter id currently it's a law in texas
but i oppose that law because
i think you don't post voter id you
don't think the most
sacred obligation of our republic you
should have to prove
who you are in order to vote so there
are a lot of texans actually hundreds of
thousands who don't have a driver's
license who
don't do they have a social security
number
because according to this republican law
you can put your last four digits
of your social security number in as
proof of who you are did they not
help me out do those people not have
social security numbers and who are
these people that can't get ids
so pete if you're talking about the bill
that we're currently focused on not
past texas law what this bill is going
to do is not only reduce
voting hours it's also going to empower
these partisan poll watchers who are
going to look over voters shoulders
and artists and politicians weren't
allowed
in certain states at certain times in
certain places whether you agree with
that or not
so texas says maybe we should have
partisan poll watchers on either side
republicans and democrats right it
wouldn't just be republicans
do you remember you remember a second
ago when i talked about the big lie this
is exactly what i'm talking about the
reason that so many folks
we're not talking about that we just you
just went on national television said
you don't want voter id
revealing exactly what democrats and
it's so condescending to say that people
can't get identification
do you have you found someone in your
district that can't get identification
you have made a lot of money personally
and you've enriched a lot of
corporations with advertising by getting
on here and spewing lies
and conspiracy theories to folks who
trust about mike so what i'm asking you
to do is
to tell your voters right now that
donald trump okay
that is he resolved the lie that is did
democrats turn out
for the voter id it's not yourself but
at least i
at least you resolved
real quick can you answer the question
did donald trump i think the election
questions i'm not don't is this an
uncomfortable
uncomfortable question for you no it's
because this is the right my question
dc and not in texas when your job is in
texas because you know it's inevitable
that this bill is going to pass
eventually you're going to have to pay
your hotel bill and go back to texas and
governor abbott will declare a special
session
so you're being used by national
democrats to try to pass h.r 1 to
federalize elections which you as a
harvard grad should know better because
the constitution
puts that in the hands of state
legislators who are supposed to be in
their state and you happen to be in
washington d.c
i i understand how you square that
circle like i can answer so
based on the the the oath that i took
for this office
i have to uphold the constitution i have
to uphold our democratic system
and i as a texas democrat i'll tell you
this we lose a lot
on the floor of the texas house we lose
votes on abortion and guns and
and are you gonna clean the state is
this number one is this how democracy is
supposed to work all right
we're going back the reason this is
different is that they're trying to rig
the rules of the game
people
your party's been obsessed with covert
standards yet yet the cdc in the white
house says
you need to wear one on a plane why
didn't you guys so all of us are fully
vaccinated they got a little plane
without a mask
if you're fully vaccinated
enjoy your time in washington dc look
forward to seeing you back in texas
maybe in weeks maybe months we'll see at
which point
voter id law may or may not get passed
wow that was interesting hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else